ما زالت الادراج الكهربائيه في محطه برلين
الرئيسيه للقطارات تعمل رغم انها توصلنا
وتوصل المسافرين هنا الى منصه قطارات
فارغه لا تتوقفوا فيها القطارات ولا
تغادرها
وكان الساعه تتوقفت هنا
اطفئت لوحه اعلاناتي توقيت القطارات وغاب
المسافرون الذين يقصدون هذه المحطه عاده
للسفر الى مختلف المدن الالمانيه
والاوروبيه فالاضراب الذي دعت اليه
نقابتان عماليتان في المانيا تمثلان قرابه
الثلاثه ملايين موظف شل حركه القطارات
والطيران في معظم المدن الالمانيه وتحرك
بالقطارات بات مستحيلا وفرض على الكثيرين
تغيير خطط سفرهم
الامر مقبول ولكن من جهه اخرى لا اجد
الامر جيدا علينا ان نبحث عن فندق جديد
لاننا غادرنا فندقنا اليوم وايضا الان
علينا استبدال بطاقه القطار التي كنا
اشتريناها للسفر اليوم
نحن هنا اليوم لانه عيد ميلادي واردنا
زياره بوتساب فانا هنا للسياحه وجئنا بحثا
عن قطار ولكن لم نتمكن من اللحاق به
وعلينا الان ان نجد وسيله بديله ولكن
الموظفين المضربين لديهم اسبابهم للاضراب